Right.
Speaking of the universities though,
I have to talk about high schools for
a minute because following her event,
I find it interesting actually
before the event and post the event,
the most emails I've gotten are
all from high school teachers,
couple from elementary,
but mostly high school teachers.
And the tone of these emails
is borderline desperate.
They are absolutely losing their minds
because they feel that they are being
compelled to indoctrinate a youth
into this type of radical Marxist
postmodernist thinking.
And even though they don't agree with it,
they see the flaws in
it and many flaws in it.
They don't feel they have a voice.
We just are afraid to speak up
the letters from teachers too.
They're unionized,
which is interesting why
they feel so terrified,
but they,
they really feel,
they're sort of feeling like this horrible
guilt that you're teaching students
what they know.
They shouldn't be teaching them,
but they don't have any choice but to
teach it and they think that it's gotten
worse with the wind government.
What's your sense?
Well,
first of all,
you always have a choice,
right?
So,
you know,
and the choice might be to stick your
neck out and risk and risk being targeted.
My experience has basically been as
if you could withstand that and not
apologize,
um,
and not backtrack,
then you can,
you can weather the storm.
So that's a good thing
that people should know.
I think the wind government isn't
absolutely reprehensible administration.
It's my fervent with wish that there
isn't a single provincial liberal left in
office after the next election.
I think.
I don't think she's a liberal at all.
I think she's far left
of where the NDP was,
say back in the 1970s.
Yes.
Working Class Organization,
I think she's apart from
financially reckless.
Um,
she's,
she's dangerous in about
six different dimensions.
I think the Ontario human rights
commission should be strapped.
Scrapped along with all of strapped.
Yeah.
Scrapped along with the
social justice tribunals.
There's all sorts of,
I think the legislation that forced the
universities to put these quasi judicial
inquisitions in place.
Like the one that raped Lizzy
shepherd over the coal should be,
um,
should be rescinded.
Uh,
and I do also agree with
your initial proposition,
which is that the l the public school
system is actually in worse shape than the
universities and it's getting worse.
It's getting worse than it
is extraordinarily rapidly.
If you go online to the Elementary
Teachers Federation of Ontario website and
read their plans for
curriculum development there
basically they basically state
forthrightly,
um,
that they're attempting to indoctrinate.
They don't use that word.
Students from kindergarten to grade
eight into the social justice ideology.
That's,
that's the purpose of education as far
as they're concerned to rectify the sins
of the past and to bring about equity,
which is of course equity is a,
anybody who talks to you about equity,
you should immediately run away
from because they're very dangerous,
ignorant,
historically ignorant
and dangerous people.
Yeah,
it's,
it's appalling.
I'm going to make a video
for high school kids.
I'm going to tell them one of the things
I would recommend to high school kids
is that as soon as the teacher
talks to them about diversity,
equity and inclusiveness,
diversity,
inclusiveness and equity.
So that's an acronym that spells die
or white privilege that they should
immediately leave the room.